what would Marla and his friends have
what is it that I have seen in terms of
this sculpture is in a crisis why did
they fall it is in a crisis Carl I yeah
I mean the two terms that that come up
quite a lot then one talks about Vienna
and prices around 1900 and they have
already been mentioned actually here as
well one of them is the vacuum of values
lasik Lee the reception of neat journey
to claim got his dad he was not the
first one but he really meant it in a
sense and it meant that that there are
no values at all basically any kind of
normative the understatement we want to
make it's not there and the second
aspect of this crisis is that what what
Klaus called Vienna at the laboratory
for the destruction of the world that
was this the austrian-hungarian empire
was his multi-cultural state many many
different ethnic groups and the unity
came under pressure around 1900 it there
were riots Vienna had elected a few
times an anti-semitic mayor who finally
by the Emperor was appointed in 1897
accidentally the same year that Mallory
was appointed as head of the State Opera
so those two things basically if in the
philosophical kind of crisis what is
value how can we kind of think of value
after in each year and what's going on
the streets how is how how how do we
lack unity or how do we kind of splinter
up and that eventually would kind of
turn into world war one of course I'm
interested to know mal which you spoke
about Maya's faith in humanistic values
is this is this whole notion of values
the death of God etc etc etc is this was
did malecon see this as a key element of
his sense of crisis
I still want to know his sense of crisis
where did it came from what what what is
it that he saw even I think everybody
had that in that time it was it was in
the air completely that this is the end
of the world and and and one needs a new
word if you look around what happened in
this this 20-year short period people
broke away from one thing and started
something new Schoenberg decided no more
tonality and right completely different
music Picasso started to express himself
in a like black and white completely
different language I mean they were
everywhere people decided that this is
the end of the world this is the unda
gang design blunders and start a new
world now why that was that that is a
very difficult question I don't know I
really have no I don't know but I think
everybody had that feeling and it's true
that I think mallar also felt it but he
was very much in love with the old one
he wasn't able to break away from it
like showing directed or like the
drastic innovators he was like like in
the lead from the rare the where he says
it's like saying goodbye to this
beautiful world this feeling of saying
goodbye and and loving it is very much
his intuition I think mother felt the
change but couldn't make the step like
what the next generation did I don't
know I come from a completely different
side actually be having lived with two
composers and again no no and I just I
think that that at least the ones I knew
had this incredible sensitivity and
capacity for feeling what was going on
in the world and what what was going on
in their lives and transmitting this in
their music and I think that they have
the people like that creative people
like that have such a intensive way of
understanding what is going on in the
world based on what they know and what
they feel and what is happening to them
but what is happening also to others
that we certainly cannot enter into
their heads and then people are always
asking me what would your husband have
said if he knew Italy today with bed
moscone what would your father think of
electronic music and that sort of thing
and I always refuse to do that because
these people were so creative and so
they had such antennas you say that that
that you know we can't really I mean
most of us Lee certainly not i can say
what would they have thought or why did
they do a certain thing we can we can
surmise we can guess at certain things
because we know of certain facts out of
their lives we know of the deaths in
mother's family that obviously had a
very great influence on him we also know
that he grew up in a shtetl and
therefore probably knew about the
different programs that had been before
so he didn't have to be a profit for the
future because he already knew what had
happened in the past and and all of
these things form the the emotional i
think of them emotional and
the sensitivity of the person and this
comes out in the music but when I listen
to the music I'm very different from all
of you because I don't know very much
about why and what it's supposed to mean
and all those things and and to me I
just I perceive the music as music and I
don't think about whether it's one thing
or no a funeral march i can tell that
it's a funeral march but but but i think
there are very many different ways also
of listening to music and how different
people perceive it oh yeah let's go
let's go back to that in 10 min in 10
minutes but just 222222 wrapped it up
okay I can accept your argument you know
we cannot go into their heads and so you
know what is basically we can say about
what they would say now but simply based
I haven't sorted okay good I thought
somehow I have an idea how how himeler
may have may react to tell us I mean I I
may be wrong but I feel because look we
know that he he conducted in Vienna a
lot of vaginal performances he was like
the vogner you know ambassador and
Wagner Wagner and we also know that the
young adult Hitler was in the audience
now imagine this scene Gustav Mahler
does his best to fight for Wagner there
is an idiot young man in the audience
who somehow gets affected by this music
and then we know what he did later with
it's such a crazy idea that actually
mother injected the love of Wagner into
Hitler I mean this this is what happened
now let's imagine that what you say
mother would sit with us and we would
tell him why did you do this
what on earth did you have in mind you
know make this this German nationalist
vogner music such a grand thing and and
hypnotize people to love it look what
Hitler did and I think mother may react
see this is exactly what I composed in
my music this controversy and this fight
and this paradox and disgrace eNOS that
is Mother's music